you've heard your whole life that you
should get eight hours of sleep every
single night it's advice so common that
even your grandma has probably told you
that at least three times but that
advice has always annoyed me somewhat
because it's like yeah obviously I
should get eight hours of sleep every
single night but how realistic is that
I'm sure there are plenty of successful
people in the world in fact I've heard
of some successful people in the world
who sleep less than eight hours a night
and they seem to be doing just fine
besides in my own life I've had plenty
of great days on six hours of sleep six
and a half hours of sleep and I've
probably had a bunch of really bad days
on eight or nine hours of sleep so how
important is getting eight hours of
sleep really does it matter that much so
in this video we're gonna get to the
bottom of it I partnered up with this
company called Sleep Number that makes
these super Advanced smart beds that
track every aspect of your sleep and
they agreed to send me one and use it
for this experiment as long as I give
them a shout out etc etc so over the
past three weeks I've been sleeping in
this bed exclusively and it's been
tracking every aspect of my sleep in
detail how much restful sleep I got how
many times I exited the bed how many
times I wet the Vietnam and while all
this tracking was going on in the
background I was just living my life and
every single day I was vlogging how I
felt you know how's my energy levels how
is my general productivity and mental
Clarity and it wasn't until the very end
of the experiment that I actually went
back reviewed the footage and paired the
footage up with my actual sleep data to
see if there was any correlation between
my energy levels My overall will to live
and the amount that I slept and the
results blew my mind and it completely
changed the way I view sleep in general
and I'm sure you'll find it extremely
fascinating as well let me show you what
I'm talking about
so I basically just woke up
um I don't feel that good
um
yeah if I were to guess I had six and a
half hours of sleep which isn't terrible
right by any means I'll have a good day
today
we did not have a good day today I just
felt brain dead Okay so brain dead was
the common theme today I probably slept
very poorly or my Sleep Quality wasn't
very good
73 it took me an hour and 50 minutes to
fall asleep I was only restful for five
hours and 49 minutes Restless for 40
minutes sub six hours of sleep this is
what I look like and this is how I
operate on sub six hours today it's 3 44
p.m I feel pretty good not fantastic I
wouldn't say I'm teeming with energy
like a hive full of caffeinated bees
I've had worse days yeah so I'm going to
assume I didn't sleep fantastically like
probably sub seven hours I'm out of
sleep let's see yeah see like I got an
83 sleep IQ score and I think the thing
that's propping up my sleep IQ score is
that I had absolutely no bed exits or
Restless sleep until the very end but
still look at that six hours and 37
minutes of sleep it's still sub seven
hours so you know I'm not feeling uh
great I'm also quite alarmed by the time
it took for me to fall asleep two hours
and 10 minutes so that was probably on
my phone for a long time I was exposed
to a lot of blue lights let's keep going
what's up
um I slept with my contacts in last
night oh my I look awful I look like
like awful like my I'm the same person
it's a slower day I'm gonna play some
video game I also was trying my blue
blockers last night so it wasn't a lot
of blue light getting yeah I look so bad
like look at me this is like degenerate
me so we can learn a lot from this I
look bad so was it the sleep was it the
quality of sleep or was it the fact that
I slept with my contacts in
77 I got six and a half hours of sleep
again well I went to bed at 3 30 a.m
like that's just not okay and I woke up
at 11. this is not the face of somebody
who is teeming with energy who's excited
about life and who has drive and
Charisma like oh look at that so I ate a
bunch of pizza last night
terrible idea and I slept awfully I look
45 years old today I look 45 years old
every day and I'm gonna see how
productive I can be I'm in a rut I'm
glad we have this as a control you can
see the difference between like how I'm
operating and like how I look and how
I'm talking in this versus like right
now 1102 p.m so this is later that day I
don't know what happened to me and now
it is 11 p.m and I'm absolutely begged
I'm looking forward to uh
just being a good person
that's so sad clearly I was wiped
68. once again man I'm loving these six
and a half six hour 45 minutes of sleep
so apparently I was Restless for an hour
and a half and that's what happens to me
when I eat pizza dude when I eat pizza
before bed gobble gobble gobble I always
have to like wake up later in the night
to like burp myself as if I'm an infant
six and a half hours of sleep is not
enough for me to feel Snappy even though
I feel like it is every single morning
I'm like oh I got six and a half hours
but as the day goes on it's proving to
be like not a great day okay today I
feel good I actually feel like I got
sleep finally like it it feels like I
got high quality sleep
I notice a world of difference I don't
know if you guys are noticing words are
coming to my mouth faster I don't look
so out of it even though this is not a
great frame to pause on my brain feels
clearer and I'm just more motivated to
do difficult things yeah we'll see how
it plays out update I just did a-roll
holy did I have energy speaking
like words were just coming to me I had
energy to say what I meant and mean what
I say it was a great experience you can
tell like I can tell anyways I still
once again don't look great but my brain
power is so much better
holy smokes what a good night's sleep 7
hours and 55 minutes of sleep so I
basically got eight hours a 95 sleep
score my mind is kind of blown right now
because you don't think that the
difference between six and a half hours
of sleep and eight hours of sleep is
that vast but clearly we can see that
I'm like two different people this is
way cooler than I thought it would be
honestly what did we get the next day
hello there
um I feel really good today right now I
feel like alert I feel awake I feel
stable I like this feeling this is
probably like the best or s or second
best that I felt I probably got like 89
90 in this one let's see 96 it was my
best one that's crazy
7.59 so I got eight hours of sleep again
that's the difference holy smokes the
two times that I've felt really good and
I'm like I feel good I can do it today
both times it's because I got eight
hours of sleep it's no joke let's see
how I continue to do as the days go on I
feel a little too good I think a lot of
that has to do with the fact that I've
been
I've been being productive yeah like
mental Clarity is just insane right now
hmm did I just get like insane sleep
last night I feel really good I had
energy for days today
I had energy to spare I had energy yeah
I was super productive hi welcome to
Chili's my energy levels
are still fantastic
and I'm going to bed now 12 p.m I no 12
A.M
that's how time works but now I'm gonna
go to sleep and uh hopefully it's a good
sleep again all right the reveal drum
roll please
85. this sleep score isn't as good as
the day before
but this is the first time ever that I
had two good nights in a row so I think
that's the difference here hey um I
played hockey last hold why did my skin
look so bad I played hockey last night
um didn't go so well I just looked bad
don't I look bad today
68. I wasn't expecting the correlation
to be this this tight the correlation is
tight so let's see what the next day was
like I just want to say today was an
absolute disaster
I feel like I barely had any sleep I
basically didn't do anything today
like it was wild I was brain dead
64 and a half hours of sleep it makes
sense yeah so this is how you want to
live your life Joey get bad sleep hey
guys
I feel really good today yesterday was
an absolute disaster I didn't do
anything today it feels completely
different it feels like I actually have
energy I have mental Clarity and I'm
making good Headway on my projects I
would be shocked if I didn't sleep well
the night before
90. guys I don't know what to say at
this point anymore
um just stop the video what else do I
need to say my entire energy my my
enthusiasm about life my ability to get
things done the confidence in myself to
be able to get things done it skyrockets
when I sleep better and all throughout
my life I've had this understanding that
like oh as long as I get six hours of
sleep I'm functional but what that
really means is like I'm barely
surviving and on six hours of sleep my
willpower goes down I make worse
decisions and not take care of myself
and play more video games which results
in worse sleep which results in
perpetuating that type of sub-optimal
Lifestyle if you can find a way to sleep
better then all of a sudden you have a
different aura about yourself and you're
able to make better decisions that will
influence better sleep going forward so
I think it's becoming far too clear that
having a lot of good quality sleep you
know know optimizing your sleep is
crucial to feeling good but if I just
ended the video here and just said
getting good sleep is good for you it
would be kind of a useless video it'd
still be kind of interesting to see how
important it is but I don't want you to
walk away from this video just being
like man I just got to get better sleep
but I have no idea how so here are some
tips that I learned through this
experiment that will help you get as
much high quality sleep as possible so
that you can go and transform your life
tip number one is that you need to get
off your phone while you're in bed I
noticed that there was a huge
correlation between the amount of time I
was spending on my phone blasting my
brain with blue light and the quality of
sleep I got because of it being on your
phone while you're trying to go to sleep
ruins your sleep for two reasons number
one is that it stops you from actually
falling asleep and it cuts into the
potential time window that you should be
sleeping and instead you're replacing
that with being on your phone and as we
learned there's a gigantic difference
between six and a half and seven and a
half hours of sleep so while you're in
bed the best use of your time is to be
asleep now this might be obvious but you
also might be thinking well I can't
really go to sleep right away and being
on my phone kind of helps me burn some
time so that when I feel that wave of
sleep I can ride it into La La Land
which I understand totally but it's a
little bit silly if you think about it
because the blue light from your phone
messes with your circadian rhythm it
tells your brain subconsciously that
it's daytime so the likelihood that
you'll actually feel this wave of sleep
is reduced and so many of us get trapped
in this cycle of just like waiting for
this wave of sleep That Never Comes so
if you're looking for something to do
while you're waiting for that wave of
sleep then I highly recommend reading a
book doesn't have to be super exciting
in fact if it's kind of boring it's
probably better you will be shocked as
to how quickly it's just lights out when
you start reading the second biggest tip
I can give is to not drink caffeine past
lunchtime and there's a very specific
reason for this I've talked about in
previous videos it's that the half-life
of caffeine is between five and seven
hours and what that means is not that
the caffeine goes away from your system
in five to seven hours it means that
half of the caffeine is still there
after five to seven hours and then it
takes another five to seven hours for
half of that amount of caffeine to leave
your system so if we average that time
out to six hours and you stop drinking
caffeine at lunch time then by midnight
you'll have about quarter of the
caffeine still in your system which
should be plenty of time for a lot of
that caffeine to be flushed away helping
you feel drowsy when you're actually
supposed to put your head on your pillow
and get some high quality sleep the
third tip I have is to make your room
colder one thing that I noticed very
clearly throughout this experiment was
that when my room was hot and I was
inclined to take off covers instead of
put them on I had way worse sleep and I
don't really know the science behind
this but you've probably noticed as well
when you have nightmares you usually
wake up in a sweat and it gets me
thinking did you wake up in a sweat
because of your nightmares or were you
having nightmares in the first place
because you were sweating and you were
super hot another thing that I noticed
is that when my room is super cold I
really want to just bundle up and get
warm it's sort of the singular focus of
my brain and it almost has a meditation
effect it brings your Consciousness away
from this cerebral cortex anxiety what
did I do wrong earlier today and it
brings your Consciousness almost to this
localized concern it's like oh I need to
get cozy oh it's nice to be cozy I think
I'll fall asleep you know it kind of
simplifies your brain into getting warm
and falling asleep it's perfect so make
your room colder another tip I have is
don't eat a bunch of pizza right before
you go to bed there wasn't much
difference between eating a light snack
and eating nothing before bed but there
was a huge difference between that and
eating a ton before bed so if I had a
bunch of fried chicken or pizza uh right
before bed it ruined my quality of sleep
it was really hard to get into deep
sleep and I had to keep on waking up
multiple times to like burp myself it's
just not a fun time so the bottom line
is if you have to sleep anyways if it's
a non-negotiable unavoidable part of
being a human being then why not find a
way to make that better somehow so that
the entire experience of living improves
because it's one to one the better the
Sleep the better you'll feel hopefully
this video made you think about why you
should get better sleep and how you
should get better sleep using some of
the things that I learned through this
sleep experiment so I hope that by using
this information that you're able to
find a good night's sleep tonight
because I feel like you deserve it
a big thank you to sleep number for
making this video possible for providing
me with this super high-tech smart bed
because without this tool this
experiment would not be possible the
sheer detail of the sleep tracking
technology present in this smart bed is
second to none it was so incredibly easy
to figure out and problem solve why I
wasn't sleeping properly not only that
but the smart bed also makes it
extremely easy to make modifications to
help you get better sleep for instance I
found that I'm just a lot more
comfortable and more likely to get into
deep sleep when my head is slightly
elevated and I also prefer the bed to be
just a little bit on the firmer side
which is easily adjustable in the app as
well and I remember there were two
nights in particular where my feet were
super cold there were like ice bricks
and for some reason they just couldn't
get warm but thankfully I remembered
that there's also built-in foot warmers
basically this smart bed does all the
heavy lifting for you so you can just
focus focus on getting a good night's
sleep so that you can tackle the next
day with energy so if you're interested
in checking out the smart bed that I
used for this experiment use my link in
the description below check out the
Sleep Number 360 smart bed and thanks
again to sleep number for sponsoring
this video if you liked this video then
make sure that you actually hit the like
button it helps a tremendous amount it
helps the video rank better it helps
push this video onto people's home pages
helping them out which also helps me out
so it's a win-win for everybody involved
if you're lurking here and this is the
billionth time that you've seen my face
then consider hitting that subscribe
button other than that I hope you
enjoyed this one guys thank you so much
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video